Monsieur le président, euh,
permettez-moi, euh.
Euh. De. De vous faire part, euh. De notre. Euh.
Indignation,
euh. Vis-à-vis, euh. Des propos que nous faisons,
que nous venons d'entendre.
On a quand-même 1 collègue,
euh. Dans cette salle de commission
qui vient accuser le Rassemblement National,
euh. De fait absolument abject.
Mais ce que nous soulignons par ailleurs,
c'est qu'elle manque de courage puisque
quand nous lui demandons
de nous donner les noms,
et bien là, il y a plus personne.
Donc, monsieur le président,
nous sommes particulièrement surpris de la tournure
que prend, euh.
Cette commission,
même si, euh. Enfin, je.
Je pense vraiment que de la nuverse,
on pouvait s'attendre à tout,
mais là, je pense vraiment que ça dépasse les bornes,
ça, c'est dans le thé.